البدايه من تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث نفذت الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه تدريبات
في مقاطعه موسكو تحاكي صدها جماعه على
منشات عسكريه وصناعيه واداريه وفي
اوكرانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها سنه هجمات في محور مقاطعه زبرجيا
وسيطرت على خطوط ومواقع مهمه بينما قالت
كيف ان القتال مستمر في سردار ياتي هدف
الوقت الذي جدد فيه اوكرانيا حلفائها
لارسال دبابات بشكل عاجل من الكرامتور
الجزيره عمر الحاج ومن موسكو امين نادر
رامي
وابدا معك امين لكن من الخبر العاجل الذي
وردنا قبل قليل عن تدريبات الدفاعات
الجويه الروسيه في مقاطعه موسكو
نعم هذا البيان الذي صدر عن وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تحدث عن تدريبات
لوحدات تابعه للمنطقه العسكريه الغربيه
اجرت
تدريبات تحاكي صدى هجمات جويه على منشات
عسكريه وصناعيه واداريه في مقاطعه موسكو
عندما نتحدث عثمان عن مقاطعه موسكو نتحدث
بالضروره عن العاصمه موسكو
لاختلاف اولا همم المنطقه التي تقع فيها
موسكو ومقاطعه موسكو طبعا وهي مساحه شاسعه
او مقاطعه شاسعه جدا
وبالتالي همم لربما ال- همم هنا من هنا
تاتي اهميه هذه المناورات كما تاتي من همم
اهميتها طبعا من توقيت اجرائها بعد همم
الاستهدافات طبعا المتواليه لاهداف عسكريه
داخل العمق الروسي قناه روسيا قد اتهمت
الجانب الاوكراني همم بها وايضا ما تم
تداوله على مستوى وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
خلال همم هذا الاسبوع عن ان وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه كانت قد نشرت مضادات جويه وانظمه
دفاع جوي في بعض المناطق وسطى همم العاصمه
الروسيه وكانت همم وكان الكريملين
وبالتحديدنا المتحدث باسم الكريم لا يقدر
همم رفض تعليق عن هذه المعلومات وقال بان
وزاره الدفاع هي المخول بان همم يرد ويفسر
هذه
المعلومات ايضا الاشاره الى ان العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو همم مزوده بنظام الدفاع جوي
يخضع بشكل دوري وايضا
مرحله لتدريبات عسكريه لقوته
وطبعا هذا الدرع لنقل يحمي سماع العاصمه
الروسيه موس كل التي يقطونها طبعا كمان
على اكثر من 18 مليون نسمه بعد ذلك طبعا
ميدانيه اليوم وزاره الدفاع تحدثت عن تقدم
لقواتها في مقاطعه زبروجيا بعد الحديث
الذي دار خلال يومين عن تنشيط جبهه
زابروجيا تحدثت عن السيطره على خطوط
ومواقع عسكريه هامه للجيش الاوكراني في
تلك المنطقه وايضا تحدث عن سيطرت قواتها
على منطقه جديده وهي بلده تقع الى الجنوب
من سوليدار الوزاره ايضا في بيانها اليوم
تحدثت عن استهدافات لتجمعات للقوات
الاوكرانيه ايضا لمخازن ل- ااه السلاح
ومواقع عسكريه اوكرانيه في عديد من
المقاطعات من خارج كيف مرورا بلو غاز
كدونيس وايضا فيزباروجين في خر سوف نستمع
الى ما قالته الوزاره في هذا الشهر
في محوريجا والنتيجه للعمليات الهجوميه
سيطره وحدات المنطقه العسكريه الشرقيه على
خطوط ومواقع مهمه خلال يوم واحد قضينا على
30 عسكريا اوكرانيا وعدد من الاليات وفي
محور دونيتك سيطره وحدات متطوعين بدعم جوي
وصاروخي على بلده ديفراتشي في جمهوريه
الشعبيه لقد بلغت خسائر الجيش الاوكراني
نحو 50 عسكريه بين قتيل وجريح
ولكن قبل ذلك تحول الى عمر الحاج عمر
اوكرانيا النفت خساره مواقع في مقاطع كما
اعلنت موسكو وايضا اسالك عن تطورات جبهه
سردار القريبه من حيث انت
نعم عثمان بيان قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
اكد ان لا شيء يتغير في خطوط التماس في
الجبهات في مقاطعه في الجنوب هذه الجبهه
التي كانت تشهد سكون او رتابه منذ عده
اشهر حتى ربما اكثر من سته او سبعه اشهر
لم يكن فيها اي عمليات قتاليه كان هناك
فقط قصف متبادل وسجل فيها في شهر في شهر
اكتوبر الماضي مقتل اكثر من 40 مدنيا
كانوا يحاولون العبور من مناطق سيطرته همم
القوات الاوكرانيه في المقاطع الى مناطق
سيطره القوات الروسيه عن ذلك ان يكون فيها
اي تغيير وان كانت خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
تتحدث القوات الاوكرانيه عن تعزيزاتنا
عسكريه تساقط ومن قبل الجانب الروسي خاصه
الى مناطقي خط الاشباك بين همم الجانبين
في الشوط الثاني من السؤال هنا في المنطقه
الشرقيه عثمان الروايه الاوكرانيه مبتسمه
بالتحفظ وعدم التعليق حتى على اي تصريحات
روسيه وهي اعلان الروسيه على عن السيطره
على مواقع جديده سواء اعلان يوم امس
السيطره على كلاش كيف في بالقرب من ضخم او
قبلها الاعلان عن سيطرتي اوبتنا ومناطق
اخرى الروايه الاوكرانيه ملتزمه بالقول ان
المعارك ما تزال مستمره في كل هذه اعجابات
حتى سوليدار التي اشارت تقارير
الاستخباراتيه البريطانيه الى انها سقطت
بعيد القوات الروسيه عشره من الشهر الحالي
فيها ما تزادوا مستمره في همم كان القوات
الاوكرانيه شرعت منذ ايام بشق الخنادق
بحفر الخنادق ووضع خطوط الدفاعيه داخل
شوارع المدينه داخل احياء المدينه بعد ذلك
تسيطر عليها في خطوه همم يرى انها استعداد
السيناريو الاسود يحارب شوارع في هذه
المدينه خاصه مع ان البيئات الاوكرانيات
تحدث عن عزم القوات الروسيه على تركي
عمليات هذه العسكريه في
الفتره القادمه للسيطره على مدينه باخوك
الغايه في الاستراتيجيه حاكم مقاطعه
دونيسك ايضا تحدث عن مقتل ثلاثه مدنيين
وجرح عشرات الاخرين في قصف الروسيين استاد
فنادق سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
دونيسكو اشاره مره اخرى الى توسعه في
العمليات العسكريه في المنطقه الجنوبيه من
هذه المقاطعه وان كانت هي الاخرى تمتاز
بنوع من الرتابه والهدوء مقارنه مع باقي
المناطق نعم عمر كاترين انتي فيك وهذه
التطورات الميدانيه تترافق مع اعلان
اوكراني انها ستبدا تدريب قواتها على
دبابات ليوبارد الالمانيه
[موسيقى]
صح يا عثمان رغم عدم الاتفاق بالامس في
رانشتاين على تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات
وهو مكانها مطلبها الاساسي طوال الاسابيع
الماضيه ايمانا منها بان هذه الدبابات سوف
يكون لها دور اساسي في في الميدان وفي
تعزيز قدراتها القتاليه في الحرب التي
تشنها عليها اوكرانيا كما تقول ولكن رغم
ذلك اعلن وزير الدفاع الاوكراني في
تصريحات صحفيه ان انه رغم ذلك تم الاتفاق
في اينشتاين بين عددا من الدول على ان
تقوم القوات الاوكرانيه بمهام تدريبيه على
دبابات همم لا برده اثنين ال- الالمانيه
التي كانت تامل في الحصول عليها اوكرانيا
وان ذلك سوف يحصل بدايه بولندا كما قال
الوزير الاوكراني وقال نبدا من هنا ولكن
نمضي قدما الى الامام لاحقا متحدثا عن
تفاؤل يشعر به حياله ان اوكرانيا سوف تحصل
لاحقا على هذه الدبابات على من التردد
الالماني الحالي بهذا الخصوص وقال ايضا
دعا القياده الالمانيه الى ان تقوم
بمشاورات داخليه بهدوء ايضا الرئيس بلنسكي
اوحى واشرب من خلال خطابه المسائي امس بعد
انتهاء اجتماع على اينشتاين بان اوكرانيا
سوف تمضي قدما في نضالها همم المستمر من
اجل الحصول على الدبابات التي قال ان لا
بديله عنها في هذه الحرب كذلك المستشار في
رئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بولدياك همم غرد
قائلا ان التردد العالمي فيما خص تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات هو يقتل يوميا مزيدا من
الاوكرانيين وقال لم لا تملك كثيرا من
الوقت علما اننا زنسكي ايضا كان قد اشار
الى عامل للوقت وان الامر لا يحتمل مزيدا
من الارجاء فيما يخص التسليح اوكرانيا
بمزيد من المعدات الثقيله بما فيها ايضا
الاسلحه الهجوميه اذا كل هذه المواقف
عثمان تؤشر الى ان اوكرانيا لا ترى او ترى
ان المعركه بالنسبه لتزويدها بدبابات لم
تنتهي هنا عند اجتماع رمشتاين بالامس
خصوصا وانه هناك اجتماع اخر همم كثيره
اينشتاين متوقع عن عقده في الشهر المقبل
تزامنا مع ذكرى الاولى للحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كان سنسكي بالامس تحدث عن انه
يامل ان يحصل خلال الاجتماع المقبل على
مقاتلات اف 16 وكذلك على صواريخ بعيده
المدى اذا الامل في اجتماع على مشتاين همم
المقبل في ان تحقق اوكرانيا كما تؤشر اليه
خطاباته مسؤليها على ما عجزت عن تحقيقه في
اجتماع على مشتاين بالامس الان نستمع
عثمان الى ابرز ما جاء في كلمه الرئيس
الاوكراني بالامس التي اكد فيها ان النضال
من اجل الحصول على الدبابات سوف يستمر
البرنس
بكل ما يلزم حتى تحقيق النصر لا يساله
يتعين علينا النضال لتوفير دبابات حديثه
لكننا نوضح كل يوم انه لا بديل عن ضروره
اتخاذ قرار في هذا الشان اشكر جميع
الشركاء الذين دعموا بوضوح الموقف
الاوكراني هناك نتائج جيده بالنسبه لتوريد
المدرعات
وستضاف مئات منها لترسنتنا اضافه لنتائج
مهمه فيما يتعلق بالقضاء في الصاروخيه
والمدافع المضاده للطائرات شكرا لكم